but I had a
performed at a holiday party this past
weekend and thought I'd get me a fancy
pen to make me feel good for this
feel-good show so we got us a uniball
207 plus so lovely it's got a nice
smooth grip
it's got a good just overall balance and
it just looks good when you write with a
good pin you just feel good and as Deion
Sanders says
when you look good you play good when
you play good they pay good so
this Eddie Bauer Henley may not look the
best but this uniball 207 is getting
litty so the word of the day is C
and today's date is
the seventh
12-7 slash 22 I will try to stay in
frame
excuse me my friends
maybe if I zoom out a little bit that'll
help
I'll try to write I'll try to I'll try
to stay proper
try to stay proper
put the name of the game here
we're about to for 10 minutes write a
new joke using the word c so feel free
to ride along with me
shout out ideas in the live stream that
we do on this every single Wednesday
and without further Ado my friends
welcome to the right 10 Club
10 minutes on the clock
all right
so 10 minutes the word of the day is
C
so the first thing we like to do is just
brainstorm a bunch of different things
that come up when you think of the word
c what are associations what are
connections what just verbal mental
vomit get all the ideas you have out and
we're just brainstorming right now we're
not trying to be funny we're just trying
to get as many ideas out on the page as
possible that then we can then structure
into a joke so first things up see you
know I mean there's no wrong idea here
as well ocean
seaweed okay so seaweed there could be
some sort of play there on like weed
weed and seaweed perhaps
um
ships ships Titanic
seasick
um
Atlantic Ocean
golf Mexico
um
Bermuda Triangle
Bermuda Triangle could also be a name of
seaweed perhaps you know but right now
we're still just getting ideas out there
um lost at sea
I know this is kind of angled but this
is how I'm writing it's a it's a weird
it's an awkward angle here
c c Hawks
so perhaps something with that uh
perhaps something with the football team
the Seahawks
um let's see CCC
and you could also do word plays so it
could be
c as in s-e-e could be c as in C in
Espanol
um
c as in someone's name CC
and also when we think of C what do we
think of waves
Sandbar uh Beach
bottom of the sea
there's also that tuna company what is
it chicken of the sea
um
hmm
CCC okay so we got about seven minutes
left as we're brainstorming here usually
to brainstorm the first half of it
but if something strikes you feel free
to run with it
and as I'm looking at what I have here
see ocean seaweed ships
Titanic seasick Atlantic Ocean
Gulf of Mexico waves sandbar
surfing
um common phrases I see you like for IC
CC
um I see you
see through you
see sick
so something that's um
standing out here
the seaweed thing still feels like
there's the most potential for maybe a
word play there
lost at sea seasick
so they're coming down to about halfway
through
see we it just feels like the obvious
choice but in 10 minutes our goal here
is to not
um over complicate our goal is just to
get a funny idea out there in 10 minutes
which is easier said than done so should
probably get to work on it so let's go
with the seaweed then okay
let's let's play with this let's play
with this premise here because the idea
we're trying to go through here is like
seaweed
and then like
weed weed
so we could do some parallels here
of like what are the differences and
similarities
um green
uh you smoke
Vape
you vape it
you roll it not that I know any of these
things
um
green maybe grow in water
how about salt water
um it is edible
okay both are edible huh so there's
something we can maybe play with there
of like edible weed weed and edible
seaweed
I've seen the seaweed snacks before
foreign
loud
so now that we've gotten a few ideas out
there we're trying to find like a funny
mistrict we're trying to find a nice
setup punch for this so
think of Wee we would think of seaweed
what would be
an example of like seaweed perhaps it
could be something
from like uh Captain a captain
Captain Crunch
over here we have Snoop Dogg so maybe
someone named like Captain Snoop
um
and when we think of C maybe C levels
Rising
so maybe there's a play with like global
warming there
climate change
ice
melting
DonTrell said seaweed wrap oh yeah
that's interesting
seaweed rap like you're rolling up uh
seaweed that's funny
um
Captain Hyatt C high c
High Noon
all right as we got about two and a half
minutes yeah
one thing that can help the direction of
a joke is also like finding out like you
gotta you gotta solidify like what is
your premise here what are you trying to
say with this joke so for this joke
what is my premise what am I trying to
say
and that's a great question
um
that seaweed is different from weed weed
Studies have shown that seaweed is
edible
High Tide high Tide
is another um
sea turtles
there's another Association sea turtles
edible you can eat both maybe there's
something there
legal
so maybe it's illegal to
um forage for seaweed
I'm not really sure what the premise is
I think right now I'm just thinking
through
seaweed and weed
um
Snoop okay but the last minute Joel
let's let's get something out of here
okay so
salt water
seaweed edible I think there's something
with edible there
um
edibles
maybe it's um the last edible I ate
made me sick
never eat
seaweed
oh maybe the
the last edible I gave me mercury
poisoning
mercury poisoning
seaweed
all right all right
in 10 minutes
let's wrap it up here my friends feel
free to comment with the jokes you came
up with
and the name of the joke writing game is
that
you write 20 jokes and you maybe keep
one of them and some people may watch
this and be like oh you idiot you didn't
find comedy gold in 10 minutes
and that's your prerogative that you can
um project your
comedic genius through a YouTube video
so good for you for feeling that
judgment but I've been doing comedy over
12 years I've interviewed over 400
Comedians and I understand the creative
process of writing a joke and then it's
not always
gonna always so this one
things I could have done better really
get to a premise quicker I really just
thought of seaweed and then was like oh
there's probably some funny thing going
on there but
at the end of the day
didn't really quite land on anything
specific I mean
the closest we got the last edible I ate
gave me mercury poisoning
that's the last time I eat seaweed or it
never eats seaweed
yeah
or the last edible I ate was too salty
that's the last time I have seaweed
something like that you know
so
go forth with the old days my friends
thank you all for hanging out and
watching this I hope you found some
maybe better jokes than I did today but
this is all part of the writing process
so just know that
they're not all gonna all my friends but
the whole goal is that you show up and
you're right every single day and get
yourself closer to finding that next
great joke